hey everybody it's Mike freder here with
on call compliance Solutions and I'm
back with another compliance tip of the
week this week we are talking about cmmc
control mp. L2
3.8.8 prohibit the use of portable
storage devices when such devices have
no identifiable
[Music]
owner so hey if you're a defense
contractor who's feeling overwhelmed
tired and alone trying to understand all
the cmmc def bars and N SP 171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you found your home here at
on call compliance Solutions where we
can help you transform like a little
caterpillar into a butterfly baby into
your company's on call compliance Hero
Let's get into it if you don't know
whose USB drive or portable hard drive
it is your first action should not be to
jump up and down and stomp on it and uh
like light it on fire until it no longer
functions or works anymore then throw it
out of the building like a grenade that
could explode at any time that is
probably not what you should do my
friends um but obviously it is a very
real security risk to take a portable
storage media that is not identified and
inserted into your systems just to see
what is there that is an equally silly
idea so what's the solution we recommend
turning any unidentified devices over
the IT department to for View and
sanitization Via a computer in a DMZ or
such air or or other like air gap system
as an example so in other words isolate
a system run a scan make sure it's okay
figure out what's really going on with
it then you can use it ready to find out
more let's see what these assessors are
looking for on this one as I stab myself
in the finger with my pointer because
there's a tip on it and a button on it
and I hit the tip and definitely stab my
finger and I might be bleeding what are
the assessors looking for determine if
the use of portable storage devices are
prohibited when such devices have no
identifiable owner well pretty
straightforward implement the it us and
cyber security policy
ding uh policy mandates that no portable
storage devices shall be used when there
is no identifiable owner yes this is a
policy control you got to have a policy
uh and then you're going to have to
demonstrate that that doesn't really get
done and hey and on call we work with
defense contractors just like you who
have had this defar nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped in their laps
like a seagull on a sunny day we teach
you how to level up and be a proper on
call compliance hero for your company
eliminating gaps gray areas and getting
this solved all while showing you how to
leverage compliance is your secret
weapon to land more Defense work with
higher profit margins now that's what
becoming an on call compliance hero can
do for you if you're looking for more
help getting compliant our compliance
experts are always on call for you visit
cmmc compliance secrets.com or check out
the bio below for links to get help
right now if you love the content we're
putting out there for you help us out
with a big thumbs up on that like button
or even better smash the Subscribe
button to get the latest compliance
content as soon as our compliance nerds
roll it out until next compliance tip my
friends stay safe and secure out there
and hit us in the comments below to let
us know what you'd like to know more
about when it comes to information
security and compliance I'll see you on
the next
[Music]
one